Americans in Sudan have been told to
stay off the streets because of an
outbreak of political violence in the
east African nation a power struggle
between two military factions is blamed
for killing around is blamed rather for
around 100 killings in the past few days
Ramey inocencio is tracking the violence
that threatens to wipe out hopes of
creating a democracy there
Sudan sliding into chaos
now in open Warfare for a third day it's
Armed Forces against its most powerful
paramilitary group
an estimated one hundred thousand strong
American Lakshmi parthasarathi is
trapped in Khartoum the capital with her
drone she captured smoke rising from the
now closed International Airport I don't
think anyone expected
this to happen a passenger plane had
been hit with deaths reported people in
the terminal trembled on the floor in
this fog of War both militaries now
claim control of key installations
at the heart of this hatred the
breakdown of their leaders agreement to
integrate a power sharing deal in 2021
between the Army Chief General Abdel
fatah al-burhan and the head of the
rapid support forces General Muhammad
hamdan dagalo now smashed despite a coup
they LED together against a civilian
government people in Sudan want the
military back in the barracks
they want democracy Secretary of State
Anthony blinken called for the
protection of non-combatants
the un's food assistance program has
been suspended after three staffers were
killed
with civilians suffering the most
Sudan TV is now off air after gunshots
were fired the feed going blue
and a human rights activist says people
are running out of food and water after
the past three days fighting continues
across this country Tony with no end in
sight
raymie thank you very much